[Music]
on this friday night ferry fire
the alarming moments on the way to
prince edward island mounting casualties
of a health care crisis we are seeing no
sense of urgency from the provincial
government another helpless person dies
waiting for medical attention fighting
to protect young athletes how many more
seven-year-old children need to be
abused the amplifying calls to
investigate gymnastics canada
and a grueling life in the fast lane
the runner who bounced back to break
into the record books
[Music]
global national with bara nasser
reporting tonight mithu gancia good
evening and thanks for joining us
another day and we're learning of yet
another health care tragedy with health
care resources pushed past the breaking
point this summer is becoming a grim
ritual of deaths that have traditionally
been considered avoidable at canadian
hospitals as ross lord explains in
tonight's top story making matters worse
those who speak out are sometimes being
shouted down by government and health
care authorities
at canada's overcrowded and understaffed
emergency departments tragedy is
becoming routine an elderly woman at
lionsgate hospital in north vancouver
died after lying on a stretcher in the
emergency waiting room for two days the
nurses that work at lionsgate are
absolutely devastated about the incident
that happened last sunday
and there they have been fearful
that such an incident was going to
happen
for months and months the latest in a
growing series of deaths of people
awaiting care in various parts of canada
i think there's going to be
unfortunately more of these stories
there's certainly nothing that's
happening right now that's going to
resolve this problem in the next few
weeks or months from what i'm seeing
among the challenges getting everyone in
healthcare to work together we are
alarmed
that today we have seen no sense of
urgency from the provincial government
at a news conference thursday labor
unions and frontline ontario nurses
pleaded for more support it's also not
rare for us to be called on our way home
to come back to the hospital after
working an 8 or 12 hour shift or be
asked to short shift meaning finishing
working at 11 30 pm
and come back to work at 7 30 a.m
because the burnt out nurse couldn't
show up the statement from the ontario
hospital association said it deeply
values the hard work and dedication of
health care workers and is working to
make sure there's as much support as
possible the oha said a team ontario
approach is critical and that this
commitment to common cause was not
demonstrated by labor unions at their
news conference
now the gloves are coming off the
service employees union accuses the
hospital association of hiding behind
hollow talking points instead of making
a commitment to solutions it says the
lack of transparency as emergency rooms
close is a dereliction of duty from
hospital executives
using adversarial language against
people who call out life-threatening
deficiencies can make the health care
crisis even worse according to the cma
we can only feel like we're on the same
team when our lived experience daily is
being recognized and acknowledged and
people feel that there's transparency
and accountability for what's going on
in the system and i think if we can move
towards that but first she says things
are likely to get even worse in a crisis
everyone in healthcare saw coming made
worse by the pandemic with no obvious
and insight
ross lord global news
in the u.s the january 6 hearings
wrapped up for the summer with another
day of jaw-dropping testimony and video
evidence
i don't want to say the elections are
but i just want to say
congress has certified the results
without saying the election is over okay
these outtakes of donald trump's video
message to his supporters on the night
of the riot a key piece of evidence they
show how trump wanted to call the
capitol riders patriots and was still
refusing to concede he lost the election
jackson proskow has more on thursday's
explosive testimony and what's ahead
when the committee resumes its hearings
in september
fully aware his supporters were
attacking the capitol president donald
trump sat in his private dining room and
watched it all unfold on tv president
trump did not fail to act during the 187
minutes between leaving the ellipse and
telling the mob to go home
he chose not to act
the january 6 committee heard how trump
made no calls to the military or police
or anyone else for help for more than
three hours and instead sent a tweet
attacking vice president mike pence
who quickly became the target of the
enraged mob looked like fuel being
poured on the fire if we lose
any more time we may have we may lose
the ability to
leave they are on the second floor
moving in now recordings of secret
service radio chatter show the panicked
effort to protect the vice president as
the crowd closed in
smoke down step by unknown smoke
downstairs an unidentified witness
testified that agents openly feared for
their lives am i talking about it but um
there were calls to
say goodbye to family members so and so
forth it was getting
for whatever the reason was on the
ground the vp detail thought that this
was about to get very unclean trump ally
senator josh hawley gave a fist pump to
the crowd before the riot but was later
seen running away in new video released
by the committee
even more startling video showing the
rioters hung on every word from the
president that day including his
eventual call to go home so go home
we love you you're very special
he says go home the committee suggests
both action and inaction speak to
trump's intent and they promise there's
still much more to come doors have
opened new subpoenas have been issued
and the dam has begun to break
the hearings are expected to resume in
september with the committee suggesting
there are now multiple new avenues for
investigation at the same time there's
increasing scrutiny on the justice
department as it weighs whether former
president trump should face charges
neither
jackson proskow in washington thanks
jackson and one more note on this donald
trump's former adviser steve bannon has
been found guilty of contempt of
congress a jury found bannon guilty of
two misdemeanor counts for refusing to
provide testimony or documents to the
house committee investigating january 6.
each count is punishable by anywhere
from 30 days to one year behind bars or
fines ranging from 100 to 100 thousand
dollars
hockey canada has launched an
investigation into allegations of a
group sexual assault involving members
of the 2003 world junior team
in a written statement hockey canada
says upon learning of the allegations it
immediately contacted the halifax
regional police who say an investigation
has now been started the 2003 world
junior championship was hosted in
halifax and canada's team included
multiple players who went on to nhl
careers hockey canada says it is
committed to bringing an end to the
culture of silence in hockey and is
calling for anyone with knowledge of
this incident to contact police
one month after the federal government
froze its funding for hockey canada it
has now done the same for gymnastics
canada ottawa says the organization
needs to commit to an independent
investigation into abuse allegations
before it can access the money at the
same time the organization's own
athletes are also escalating their calls
for action david aiken explains
the open letter from the group calling
themselves gymnasts for change has 500
signatures
a lot of these signatures have come with
stories of abuse one catalyst for the
letter was the arrest of a 33 year old
male gymnastics instructor in lethbridge
charged with the sexual assault of a
seven-year-old girl how many more
seven-year-old children need to be
abused before
we realize that we need to do something
immediately we have been calling since
march for an independent investigation
into the toxic culture of gymnastics
canada and we have been ignored that
independent third party is supposed to
be the office of the commissioner of
sports integrity that's a new federal
agency created to take on complaints
from athletes who have concerns about
their sports federation's ability to
investigate themselves
but until sports federations register
with this new commissioner that
commissioner has no authority to
investigate the very complaints the
gymnasts are making and that's why
ottawa suspended the three million
dollars in federal funding gymnastics
canada receives every year to compel it
to register so that the commissioner has
the authority to investigate i just
think we need to start diffusing the
power at the top you know with these
organizations again that have sort of
been doing all of this without any
oversight yes we're demanding that they
sign on to the organization for
integrity and sports
as a condition to flow funding but they
shouldn't be worried about satisfying
the government they should be worried
about satisfying parents across the
country that they're keeping their kids
safe even still some worry the new sport
integrity commissioner is still too
close to the national sports federations
i don't trust it
because it's not completely independent
when looking at abuse it needs to be
completely independent and completely
removed
from sport organizations and even so
more may be required
i think ultimately i do think there
needs to be a body that is created by
athletes for athletes that start to you
know navigate this system with our best
interest in mind as for gymnastics
canada it said in a statement it is
working quote tirelessly to complete its
agreement with the sports integrity
commissioner david aiken global news
ottawa
a frightening experience for passengers
on a ferry sailing from nova scotia to
prince edward island after a fire broke
out on board and they had to abandon
ship
182 passengers and 18 crew were on the
north umberland ferry when the fire
erupted in the engine room at around 11
15 this morning before the ship ran
aground as alicia drouse reports it was
all hands on deck to get everyone off
the ferry quickly and safely
it's an unusual way to de-board a ferry
but passengers aboard the northumberland
ferry traveling from nova scotia to
prince edward island friday morning had
to slide to safety after a fire broke
out on board the ferry departed caribou
nova scotia at 10 a.m friday morning it
was scheduled to arrive in pei at 11 45.
it was just minutes from docking when
something went wrong
first indication was they just put these
alarms off which were quite loud but
that they they sent an alarm different
times when you're getting off the boat
so not everybody knew what it was right
away um and then probably five minutes
later through the alarm that someone got
on and announced that there was a fire
in the engine room the fire in the
engine room prompted an evacuation from
the boat passengers were asked to line
up on the deck on the opposite side of
the ship from the engine room and were
all given life jackets the smoke started
to gather a bit
and there were a few people that were a
little paranoid
i spoke with one lady who had been
through a fire at home and she was
traumatized but
most people dealt with it pretty much in
stride passengers say the rescue went
smoothly thanking crew for their quick
action and all those nearby who came to
help the lobster boat there first and
then the coast guard came in there was a
pleasure yacht from the states came over
and they ferried people ashore as well
i'm really glad it didn't happen in the
middle of the straight we would have had
a different story completely all 182
passengers and 18 crew members
disembarked with no injuries and as a
precaution northumberland ferry
suspended the remaining trips for the
day on thursday the 10 a.m ferry
departure from nova scotia was canceled
due to technical issues northumberland
ferries posted to facebook after saying
those issues were resolved the company
did not respond to inquiries about
whether or not those technical issues
had any relation to the fire on friday
alicia drouse global news
rogers has a new chief technology
officer in the wake of that huge service
outage which offline the company's
network impacting millions of customers
across canada the telecom giant promised
to make investments to avoid a repeat of
the network-wide outage and has
confirmed staffer jorge fernandez is
stepping down from his role of chief
technology and information officer
effective immediately he will now be
replaced by ron mckenzie previously the
president of rogers for business who
also spent 10 years with shaw
communications on monday mackenzie and
two other rogers executives will be
testifying about the outage on
parliament hill
it is a virus that hasn't been detected
in the u.s in years coming up the case
that has health officials on alert
police in brazil say at least 18 people
were killed during a raid in rio de
janeiro which targeted a criminal gang
in one of the city's largest favelas
residents chanted for justice as they
carried some of the dead and injured out
of the fafela following the police raid
16 of the victims are said to be
suspected criminals while a police
officer and a bystander were the other
two officials say some 400 officers took
part in the operation
[Applause]
hundreds of sri lankan security forces
moved in on protesters in colombo early
this morning as they work to clear
demonstrators that have been camped out
in the nation's capital for weeks police
described it as a special operation to
take back control of the area occupied
by sri lankans enraged with the
country's economic collapse the raid
came just hours before the island
nation's new president swore in a fresh
cabinet
for the first time in nearly a decade
polio has been detected in the u.s
new york health officials say an
unvaccinated adult tested positive for
the disease earlier this week but is no
longer contagious polio was one of the
most feared diseases in the late 1940s
with annual outbreaks causing thousands
of cases of paralysis many of them in
kids a mass vaccination campaign that
started in 1955 led to the u.s being
declared polio free in 1979
a judge has ruled prince harry can take
the british government to court over his
security arrangements in the uk
prince harry and his wife meghan markle
the duke and duchess of sussex lost
their publicly funded police protection
when the couple stepped down from royal
duties and moved to the u.s back in
2020. prince harry wants to pay for his
own security when his family returns to
the uk and is challenging the
government's decision not to allow that
homecoming mission ahead how some
canadian veterans banded together to
help a comrade badly injured in ukraine
at least three bodies have been
recovered from the rubble of a school in
the eastern ukrainian city of kramatorsk
local officials blame russian shelling
which also damaged more than 80
residential buildings in the area moscow
says it targeted the school because it
was being used as a base for ukrainian
troops and claims the strike killed more
than 300 soldiers neither claim has been
independently verified
a canadian badly wounded while serving
with the ukrainian armed forces is
recovering in an ottawa hospital tonight
the retired veteran who served three
decades with the canadian forces was
part of the international legion a
contingent of global troops helping to
fight russian forces in ukraine jeff
semple has his remarkable rescue story
in this global news exclusive
almost every day for two months erica
received a text message that her dear
friend jt was ok i didn't know
when he left for ukraine
if i ever would see him again in march
the 50-year-old recently retired
canadian veteran traveled to ukraine to
join the fight a couple of months later
his truck hit an anti-tank mine jt was
rushed to hospital clinging to life i
was really scared erica spent weeks
trying to arrange his rescue but was
told the canadian government couldn't
help and a private air evacuation was
too expensive so she called a lifeline
he's one of us i mean you know no no man
left behind this veteran served in the
same brigade as jt in kandahar he and
others have spent the past year rescuing
refugees from afghanistan and ukraine
then in may they learned one of their
own was in trouble jt was badly injured
in hospital close to the front line and
far from any border you've got a wounded
guy in ukraine there's no government
support available so how do you get
somebody back from a situation like that
this really was a canadian team effort
over several weeks the group of veterans
and health workers came up with a plan
jt was transferred between six different
ukrainian hospitals before finally
catching a flight out of warsaw and last
week he touched down here in toronto
it was very emotional
super amazing to get to see him again it
was an enormous
an enormous sense of relief
global news spoke to jt whose last name
were withholding by phone from his
hospital bed it's impossible for me to
not get emotional
um because
you know if i talk about alone
the amount of people that have come
forward to assist me he suffered a
broken neck fractured ribs burns a
concussion and nerve damage but
incredibly he says he doesn't regret his
decision to go
i saw families being torn apart you know
you want to get out there and help
because i have the ability to do so
it's it's one mind that doesn't find a
child
or a family or
like i'm good now on a long road to
recovery but grateful to be alive
jeff semple global news toronto
ukraine and russia have signed separate
agreements with turkey and the u.n which
will allow keeve to resume exports of
grain through the black sea the deal was
finalized in istanbul today putting an
end to the wartime standoff that
heightened the possibilities of an
international food crisis ukraine says
it has around 10 billion dollars worth
of grain available for sale in the wake
of the agreements
dashing into history next the record one
cross country runner just shattered
67 days after he set off from saint
john's ultra runner dave proctor has
finished his cross-country trek breaking
the trans-canadian speed record
the 41-year-old from okotoks alberta
landed at mile zero in victoria at the
foot of the terry fox statue proctor
tried to stick to the fox's marathon of
hope route as he made his way across
canada he averaged more than 100
kilometers per day and burned through 12
pairs of shoes he was emotional as he
spoke about how grateful he was to
complete the run
i'm just seeing the most beautiful
country in the world and i
suggest every canadian
to go do the very same thing and
don't run it you know get in a vehicle
and drive it or go see a part of the
country you haven't seen
but i just feel
like if i could do that i could do
bloody well anything
this was proctor's second attempt at
beating the record his first in 2018 was
cut short because of a back injury and
despite eating a treat from every bakery
across canada he still lost about 18
pounds
and that is global national for this
friday night i'm nitu garcia tonight's
your canada is this grain elevator in
battleford saskatchewan thanks for
watching tracy tong will be at the
anchor desk tomorrow and i'll see you
again on monday from edmonton for our
special coverage of the pope's visit to
canada have a great weekend
[Music]
you